nous sommes à la fois très intelligent
mais nos motivations profondes ne sont
pas forcément si intelligente que ça
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on constate les dégâts sur
la planète on arrive à anticiper ce qui
va se passer dans 20 ou 30 ans mais on
n'agit pas on change pas
fondamentalement de comportement cette
incohérence nous vient de la structure
profonde de notre cerveau si on regarde
comment sont faites les connexions dans
notre cerveau on s'aperçoit qu'il ya une
structure profondément enfouies au coeur
de notre cerveau qui s'appelle le
striatum et qu'ils nous envoient de la
dopamine donc de la récompense du
plaisir quand on réalise un certain
nombre d'objectifs simple c'est manger
avoir des rapports sexuels
à voir du statut social de la
reconnaissance de la domination avant le
plus d'informations possibles sur notre
environnement et minimiser ses efforts
c'est à dire chercher le plus de confort
possible
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans notre société de
pléthore et bien la nourriture
les contenus à connotation sexuelle les
moyens de se sentir plus important que
les autres
les sources d'information les sources de
confort sont produites au niveau
industriel de façon illimitée donc notre
striatum peut en consommer autant qu'il
veut et le problème c'est qu'il n'a pas
de fonction stop n'a pas de frein donc
il va avoir tendance à prendre tout ce
qui lui est proposé par ce système
industriel et c'est là qu'on peut
basculer dans l'addiction
c'est à dire aujourd'hui évidemment
l'addiction sexuelle qu'on commence à
connaître mais aussi de plus en plus
l'addiction à l'alimentation
et puis pour le besoin d'information
l'addiction aux réseaux sociaux et tout
cela remonte en fait à des stratégies
commerciales qu'on peut faire remonter
jusqu'aux années 20
si la norme sociale valorise la sobriété
valorise l'altruisme le partage la
lenteur dans les habitudes de vie à ce
moment là note striatum nous donnera du
plaisir par rapport à ça mais pour que
ça devienne une norme sociale il faut
que ce soit valorisée c'est à dire que
les individus qui se comporte de cette
façon soient considérés comme les
leaders de nos sociétés et pour ça il va
falloir en passer par un certain nombre
d'évolutions
[Musique]
le plaisir qu'on a à donner c'est le
seul plaisir qui ne s'émousse pas qui ne
diminuent pas au fur et à mesure qu'on
le répète si vous avez l'habitude
d'aller au fast food par exemple
peut-être vous avez noté que de jour en
jour
le plaisir baisse on augmente les doses
et bien pour l'acte de données il n'y a
pas de baisse de plaisir lié à la
répétition
donc ça pourrait être éventuellement une
solution durable et ça c'est quelque
chose qui a été découvert il ya quelques
mois par une expérience publiée dans une
revue internationale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au dessus du striatum dans notre cerveau
se trouve le cortex cérébral
c'est ce qui nous permet de construire
des fusées et des smartphones nos
sociétés ont utilisé ce cortex
jusqu'aujourd'hui pour faire de
l'intelligence de la technologie mais le
cortex a aussi la capacité de créer de
la conscience et la conscience n'est pas
l'intelligence et une autre capacité qui
est sous développée dans nos pays à
fortes valeurs industrielles et
technologiques
nous devons passer une civilisation
technologique une civilisation de la
conscience car la civilisation de la
conscience peut se retourner sur
elle-même et envisager des chemins qui
n'ont jamais été imaginé
[Musique]